So, webR is a version of R
compiled to run in a browser.
You might want to use the
containerization or sandboxing
abilities of a browser.
You might want to run sort
of literate programming type
things where you weave software
and documentation together
into a single object, or
even reproducible output.
You might have some data science
you want in a nice package that
is online, or you might
just be interested
in universal binaries.
The idea of running
a piece of software
on lots of different
machines, they could even
be mobile phones or tablets.
These are all great
reasons that I'm not
going to talk about today.
Today I'm going to talk about
why I wrote webR,
and it was actually for my
previous life as an academic.
So when I worked for
Newcastle University,
one of the things I did
was I taught R to students.
And at the end of the
semester one of the things
we do is we evaluate what
the students have learned
and we do that by asking
them to write some R code
and we evaluate how
well that R code runs.
Now during the pandemic, we
had to do that on devices
that we had no control over.
People's home devices, things
where R might not even
be installed.
We even had students doing
exams, very important exams
on a mobile phone, which is
not the best thing to do.
So the question was how
do we capture that R code
and make sure they're
doing the right thing.
Our first idea was
actually quite good.
We set a server up that
certain lessons for students
R code runs it, works
out what the answer
is, and then sends it back.
So this way we could
give the student
a website, the standard way
of evaluating and assessing
our students works.
And we just plugged
into it the service
so it sends the code away,
remembers what the student did,
marks it and then
sends the answer back.
And at first glance
it's really nice
because the students are
just writing R code
and they're just
seeing the results.
They're happy.
So we tested it, it worked.
We put it into production.
The first thing that happened
was the server crashed,
it fell over, and I had a room
full of very angry students.
So that was not ideal.
This was just before
the Christmas break.
So I went away over Christmas
and I thought, OK, well,
what can I do to solve this?
And one of the ideas I had
was to instead evaluate
that R code locally inside
the web browser instead
of using a server.
And this makes sense
because it means
you're dividing the load over
lots of different machines
instead of depending
on that one machine.
So the way this works is
that there's a technology
called WebAssembly that's
been around a few years now
but is getting more
popular very recently.
And what it is, is
a portable binary code format.
It's a bit like JavaScript, but
when it's in a certain format,
you can't read it properly.
It runs in the browser.
And what it does is enable
high performance applications
to run in a web browser
at almost native speed.
It's supported by
most modern browsers,
and you can kind of think
of it as Java, but good.
The next thing that would make
this work is Emscripten,
Emscripten is a
compiler for WebAssembly,
so it converts C code
into WebAssembly.
It's based on LLVM. Again,
it's been around for a few
years and successfully used
in a few projects.
DOSBox and SQLite have done
it along with Spoiler Alert.
Sorry Winston.
And also Emscripten
should work like this.
You give it two commands,
there's to commands
emconfigure and emmake
you give it C code
and a WebAssembly
package falls out.
When it works,
it's absolute magic.
It's incredible.
It just works.
You get some C code and it runs
online. But there's a problem.
Because R uses Fortran code.
Some of the code it's
inherited had original releases
that were in the 70s
and even worse Emscripten
can't directly
compile Fortran code.
Notice I say directly
because there's a trick.
Unfortunately, the trick
makes things a little bit more
complicated.
It looks like that. I'm not
going to go into detail.
It's very messy.
There is a link there
if you're interested in
learning more, I will point out
I think I've got
time really quickly
that there is a point
in that graph that
says choose your own chaos.
And that's because you
choose between using
an ancient version of GCC or
an unreleased version of LLVM.
So pick your poison.
It does work.
There's a website,
you can go to it
and you can run
R in the browser.
I would say do it now, but the
conference Wi-Fi is a bit iffy
and it is quite a big
package to download.
So it may not it may not work,
but when you get home, go
to the website, try it out.
You can load packages I've built
just enough of the tidyverse
so that you can actually
load ggplot in the browser
and make a plot.
It looks like that.
And, yeah, it just works.
Thank you very much.